you look good and neon
here does it
yeah so your daddy's new pet i ain't no
one's pet
yeah you are i've been thinking about
getting a pet of my own
yeah have fun with it
it's okay to watch me walk away you know
that's why we do it
kiss me what for
will make us feel better
i don't know how
me neither
don't touch me
what are you doing adjusting my web
well that's not that complicated rip
either walk on down the hall
oh [__] me
there's a music festival and there is
still this weekend with me
you ruin it every time
that's funny i always remember your dick
is being bigger
you got old
god you have an edge today
[__] you might just cheat us yet
[Music]
oh [__] you should try zumba get that
cardio up
there's [__] wrong of you
cheating dead like you said
the [__] do you want you need to go in
the house
last thing i need is you tell me what i
mean
beth there weren't a question hey
i'm the one thing you cannot wrestle
here
don't bet on it all right
nope everyone suffers today
including you
i'm trying to get a handle on all these
messes okay so just don't do anything
reckless
that's good advice maybe you ought to
take it yourself
there's such [__] children
i thought i made it clear this
it was never exclusive hmm
beth i don't care who you [__] i care
about you
and i thought we knew each other better
now
i remember the first time i saw you
so wild so angry
god you were beautiful
i remember the way you looked at him
such devotion
i was so jealous
and the way i look at you
i was worried that he'd love you more
someday
but he doesn't
i do things sometimes
how do i explain it i see things in
people and i feel like if i can touch it
even if the rest of the person is rotten
i can take that good thing and they can
make it part of me
do you understand
there's plenty of good in you beth and
none of that son of a [__]
trust me
i'm sorry i'm sorry i did that to you
no you didn't do it to me a woman you
sure can
anytime you want
and i'm sorry there's two words you
never have to say to me
i remember the stories of heaven and
hell in church
lies a lot of it
i think heaven's right here sells hell
one person can be walking the clouds
right next to someone enduring eternal
damnation
and god is the land
don't say it
it doesn't mean anything on a roof
under stars like a bunch of [__]
hippies
hey tell me
tell me when it saves me
okay i won't say it
oh
i wish i think back to life
so i could kill him again
that would be what you wish
hmm
you know we have horses right bro
just all right
what are we doing
i'm gonna read to you okay
my great-grandfather had a dream all of
his sons on the same road
the same ranch working toward the same
goal
that dream survived 100 years until me
with me it died i didn't have enough
sons
they just kept dying or quitting and one
day not too long ago
i realized that i have enough sons after
all
i don't understand
he's saying it's yours
fine
yours
[Music]
sure did
you